President Trump plans to sit down with
high school students and teachers
tomorrow for what they're calling a
listening session about school safety
the White House says it's part of a
two-week long discussion looking for a
path forward on gun legislation Margaret
Brennan is at the White House with one
change the president may support
Margaret good morning good morning well
president Trump says he does support
improving the federal background checks
system that will screen those purchasing
firearms a sign that he is at least
hearing some of the outcry from
activists and students across the
country now the President did speak on
Friday with Texas Republican Senator
John Cornyn about a bill aimed at making
the existing federal national background
check system more effective and it's
getting support from the NRA the
legislation itself would offer financial
incentives to local and state
authorities who upload information into
that system but it seems at odds with
the president's own 2019 budget proposal
which cuts 12 million dollars in funding
that was set aside for states to upgrade
those same records now White House
officials say they will take time to
consider their options here they haven't
committed to any specific actions yet
they've previously voiced support for
regulating bump stocks a device used by
the Las Vegas shooter to increase his
rate of fire but the Justice Department
and ATF review began in December and it
has not yet been completed Norah
all right Margaret thank you for that
reporting